και το είδα όιδα βουρκωμένα τα μάτια του και υγαίνω πάνω των αγκαγιάζετο και αρχίζουμε
να κλένε ένα κλέμε και οι δύο και να μου λέει και ο ίδιος δώδεγα
χρόνια είναι πάρα πολλά και τώρα φανταστείται όσι των έχουμ δύοσείδα μεο έχο δι θαδοδούν
μπορεί να τον βρούσ στης φωτογραφίες ένας άνθρωπος ια το δύο μέτρα κατονικόσυγιλά μεταμούστια μια
αφησιωγνομία που πολύ ποτ το ξε όπορ κι αδώ φοβάντερα αν τον βλέπουν τρεις φορές
τον έχοδύνα κλαίει στηστη ζωημού ο μια ήταν κέρδισα το παγκόσμιο το δεκτά στο σπλιτ
στο χόρνό που προπονούμε ιδευτα ήταν όταν κλειδωσε το αύστραννό χρισώς πριν εγκρουσάν τω μεταίον
το τόκυο άρχισε τα κλισάντω μορών και τώρα με το τατυρο με το αργυρώνμε τα
αργυρό μου στοπαρύσι και στη συνέχειαν έτσι όπως ήταν οιάπνια και εγώ σιγάικανα ισκιπλέανα φτάσω
πος τη στεριά πάλι η συγκίνηση χαρά πριεφανια ανασκόπιση να σκεφτέςε όλα φτάσι σα μια
γριγοριταινιά μέσα σου και ντάο κοντά στους δραχείο είνές νανα αναγνωρίζε ότι ο ξάδελφος μου
χωρίς πλούζα να κρατάει ψηλάδι κυπρακής σημέα και πάλει υπάρχουν αυτές σε εφοδογραφίες που πολλές
φορές λέ μια φορογακαχήγιες λέξεις ο είναι έχει για συνεθύματα οχι ημονορχήκες λέκάνες μια άδρομδοδέκατών
μεχρι αυτά στη στεριά σε αυτά τα δώδικα χρόνια υπήρχαν στιγμές που πάύλως είπε δεν
αντέχω θα τα παρατήσουν στημές που δύσκολες σίγουρα υπύρχα πολλές να σκευτό να τα παραιτήσω
ποτέ ο λόγος αυτό που κάνω το αγαπό πάρα πολύ με γεμίζει καιέχόνιρο φερ το
στόχους και όταν όσο δύσκολε φάσεις και να περνάς μεσα στη ζωήσου και μέσα από
τή μπορεία στου στων προταθητισμόν τα όνιρα είναι είναι ο φάρος ου είναι δύναμη σης